good morning guys I'm in a rush right
now because I'm heading to my Mandarin
class I've been taking it is the second
time and I'm here yeah alright so I just
finished Chinese class no I missed last
week because we were in Dallas and
luckily my classmate is so nice that she
gave me her notes to study so now I'm
gonna go meet up with Kasey and we're
gonna go hiking
alright so now Casey and I are at Eaton
Canyon
we're back at Eaton Canyon honestly this
is the only trail that we really know
because our friends keep bringing us
here I've never been to Runyon and plus
I don't want to go there there's like
way too many people
just remain celebrities we don't mingle
cool like that now there's a lot of
people are trying to look for
celebrities at Runyon Canyon so I'm like
I'm not about that
yeah so we're here we thought we'd get a
little bit of exercise in you know even
though the Sun Isaac is not with us it's
the weekend and it's been really quiet
at home I miss my baby cuz he's been
with us straight for like two months
because his dad got like some sort of
tonsil surgery or something I don't know
but he couldn't be with him for the
weekends cuz he was recuperating so yeah
we got really used to Isaac being around
the house and he's in this space where
he's singing the incredible songs the
Incredibles - theme song a lot at the
house so every like ten seconds down
here just hearing that all the time and
now that he's not home he's at his dad's
house and feels so empty like a ghost
house now since he's not at home this
weekend we just thought the house is
just like way too sad because we miss
them too much so we were like we need to
get out of the house let's go hiking
really dry it is really dry did you hear
about the fires that are happening where
oh yeah trapped and hurt and it's really
scary right now I'm surprised that it
hasn't affected our air here when I
first moved out to LA I was living in
the to hunger area the very year I moved
to that area there was a really big
forest fire in the mountains my
apartment where I was living was one
block away from the cutoff of the
evacuation area evacuation line I guess
that's what he call it evacuation from
our house we could actually feel the
heat of the fires and it was really
scary I'm like I don't mind being part
of the evacuation why because I'm scared
for my life and authorities are saying
oh you're fine you're fine you're far
away I'm okay a couple weeks following
after that we were recovered in ashes
our balcony here in the place where we
live now
we've had ashes at one point for one of
the fires I think last year you know we
have like a little side table that's
uh-huh you like the bench oh yeah you
could touch it and like all this oh yeah
how is your Chinese coming along hey how
is your Chinese by the way I'm only
taking two classes there have been three
classes I missed last week because we
were in Dallas so I really only retained
the first class because today I got
there pretty late and so like I had to
catch up from the beginning of the class
and a terrible student I am skipping
class you know heartiness are you gonna
get expelled next time I know I'm gonna
get a bad report card in the beginning
of the class there were four students
and the teacher so that was me
Gio this guy and this girl and the
teacher right I found out that the guys
stopped going because he was too
advanced for that class and then Gio
stopped going cuz she just wasn't
filling the class and so now it's just
down to me and the girl which is kind of
nice because then the teacher gets to
focus more on us so it's kind of like a
private lesson unless what there's so
many bugs around right mr. nature well
we've been learning though it's like
super simple stuff and it's just like
like a little bit of stuff so we learn
like the basics are like how to say
hello Neha me how and then what do you
say that wall head and he'll mean it
that's at me asking me like I'm you
and then you could say I don't know how
to I don't know what I'm saying
am I saying it right - I don't know I
speak Cantonese I don't speak Mandarin
so this is beyond my knowledge as well
tell me some of the Chinese have been
learning me she loves Shima what's that
mean you a teacher
take notes guys take notes three Chinese
restaurant if right now good thing
they're free cuz you wouldn't pay for
this I don't even know how to pronounce
the thing like the tones so I learned
that there are four tones I already
forgot how we go all four because the
third one she goes she kind of like
sings it yeah I don't know how to do it
right now we're learning like Pete
pinging English letters with how to
pronounce Chinese words right uh-huh
this other one I learned was Tashi see
Shane oh [ __ ] I forgot that one skip
that one okay okay this is what I
learned in the first class me mama
Helmut your mom's okay how was your mom
oh how is your mom okay mean then ping
you Helmuth your friends okay your
friends good boyfriend your boyfriend
that was your boyfriend how is your
boyfriend me mama hey mama
15 Cantonese I'm saying what you're
saying yeah what is it what are you
saying hey mama your mom that's not what
I'm saying
Oh what are you saying I'm asking if
you're busy hey mom mom oh mama
how do you say busy again mom come on
okay okay yeah and catching it small me
now go around play now go around some
kind of person and that's being what
were you like what nationality or
something uh yeah
what's make Oh young American oh that's
how use it will make on yeah for
Mandarin speakers they say the same
thing make orange Mexican is Moshe
Guerin moshe karen mok say go young I
like Mexico because it sounds just like
Mexico Mexico go any there's too many
bugs for me to focus on what you're
saying
already died we've been hiking for like
the past 30 minutes I'm like I'm good
guess what fog all around me flower
people what I don't know five five
flower it's French
oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah I'll get longer
and Chinese people yeah don't go rent
have a bingo rent Oh English people yeah
I'm gonna keep up with these classes and
hopefully it won't be so butchered you
know the more I learn when I'm speaking
Mandarin I can finally communicate with
our house cleaners cuz we can't speak to
them at all we have Michael translating
for us every time we're trying to
schedule something with them true and
then I just pantomime things and point
at calendars like next time you come
this day once I reach that level then I
know I'll be confident enough to like go
to mainland China and just get low oh
you have a great trajectory day we're
going to Hong Kong for Christmas and New
Year's and for a day or two we're gonna
hop over to mainland right yeah we think
we might be going to either like
Shenzhen or one's out one of those I
think both of those places though
speaking Cantonese oh really yeah dang
it learning the wrong language which
reminds me I wanted ask your parents if
we could save a day when we're in Hong
Kong to go to her life on it with that
she was like all right so we had three
excursions from the Hong Kong right one
of them is
be Macao one that's gonna be gone so and
then the third one well it's gonna be
Disneyland I was a yep yay that's how
you covered that for you uh I said about
you oh I should say but you're like you
know what it's really intelligent really
she said that about me yeah it's the
fact that you're constantly willing to
learn
oh it makes an intelligent person to
want to learn you know stupid people
don't learn the fact that you're working
here she's constantly needing to like
educate yourself about a lot of worldly
topics beyond that she's still trying to
learn languages you must travel and soak
in more and more and more it has a
really sweet being the same you know
that's so sweet thank you mama
they know you watch these vlogs thank
you so much
we kind of derail we stopped following
the people that were ahead of us because
I was like nah that's doesn't look
familiar I think we kept going straight
and then we started going straight and
then now we're here
I see people over there I see cars over
there I think that parking lot or just
kind of head that way so TIFF is a
person of many shortcuts no matter what
we're doing she's always looking for
shortcuts most of times it does benefit
but there are some times when it just
completely backfires and it becomes the
long way around instead of being a
shortcut you know what Steve Jobs would
have hired me you only hires lazy people
because they find the most efficient way
to do things
true true it's a nice theory hater cuz
you're the complete opposite I know the
hard way on perfectly you'll go out of
your way to do it the wrong way the most
difficult way and it just makes no sense
either so we're both the OP stubborn
general away from we're going but we'll
find ourselves in nature yay romantic
you have some water to survive for a
couple days just kidding not even
alright just got home from the hike stop
by the grocery store to pick up some
fresh salad with balsamic vinegar and
now it's gonna whip up some dinner
whatever we have in the fridge and in
the pantry we were thinking pasta cuz I
know we have some pasta and some
spaghetti sauce or something like that
in the pantry somewhere and that thing I
had some leftover chicken as well
[Music]
like I said in vlogs before I've been on
a somewhat of a gluten-free diet lately
just because through elimination dieting
and all that I've come to realize that
eczema is caused by a lot of dietary
problems I guess so for me it seems like
I'm gluten sensitive I'm super sensitive
to preservatives like the stuff in soy
sauce basically processed foods some
more process to food is the more
allergic I am to it or at least reactive
to it in terms of eczema so so tonight
I'm gonna try this new gluten-free pasta
that I've shelves off in our pantry and
for forever now but just never bother to
try it yet see what it tastes like I
don't know it looks like regular pasta
[Music]
utilize that flavor at the bottom of the
pan from the chicken to enhance that
spaghetti sauce we got using prego
tonight it's a knife and fork occasion
thanks for dinner
hero welcome sounds like someone's
peeing in the background always that
this is nice it makes not having Isaac
here a little bit more bearable so
romantic
you know we got to look at it from a
different perspective Cheers good that's
a nice line the main reason why I want
to record our dinner was because uh uh
we're contemplating whether or not to
record the dinner in really at home we
made the food but the reason why is
because I wanted to try out this
gluten-free pasta this is gluten-free
made out of rice and corn I got for your
peoples and my peoples crop this is
right here rice and corn
just like almost beginning can't tell
the difference I gave you a food mutiny
and it's all a mess now hmm I don't take
the difference I can't taste the
difference at all yeah but there's no
excuse for you not making cooking videos
you can make everything's all the time
it's so annoying to have to go out of my
way to get gluten-free ingredients and
products to make the same grocery store
where you buy regular style I like to go
to the Asian supermarket a lot of time
everything there's like way cheaper like
2/3 of the price but they don't carry
all the health conscious and like gluten
free and organic this kind of products
that you would find and say sprouts or
Ralph's I'm forced to go to like at
least two different grocery stores to
get all my anyway supplied certain
ingredients that you can get at the
Asian market so I'm just saying the year
just full of excuses I'm a man of
excuses
[Music]